so psychedelics have been used for
thousands of years and i think that they
have been used because they permit
a certain kind of escape from our ego
bound focus you know our ego is helping
us
to survive it's it's um you know we we
have abraham maslow who's talked about
the
need hierarchy and so there's um
various needs that we have and we keep
focused on that
and and we always have a sense of who we
are both for protection and for
advancement in the world and then we get
stuck in certain patterns of thought and
psychedelics
relax those patterns and they provide
this
um i'd say a good example a metaphor for
example is the
copernican revolution so everybody
thought that the earth was the center of
the universe and everything revolved
around that
and then we found that no the earth is
just revolving around
the sun and and so i think it's like
that with the ego we think the world is
revolving around
us and the psychedelics help us have
this experience no we're just a small
a bit in a larger system and um
what stan groff has talked about i
thought it was a beautiful way he said
it is that psychedelics help
the ego become transparent to the
transcendent
the ego doesn't go away the ego doesn't
die we need to be
recognizing that we're bound by birth
and death we have to
do things to survive we need that ego
but it gets enlarged you could say and
we lose
track of the bigger picture
and that's where people get depression
and meaninglessness and so psychedelics
have been
something that gives people a sense of
our participation in the larger cycles
of death and birth
and they have also been used um
i would say in in therapeutic ways to
break people out of patterns